à l'elysée le chef de l'état qui reçoit
aujourd'hui ces deux anciens
prédécesseurs françois hollande et
nicolas sarkozy
françois hollande est arrivé à 11 heures
pile il y à quelques instants un pupitre
a été adressée donc il faut s'attendre à
ce que le président est l'ancien
président s'exprime tout à l'heure
françois hollande et nicolas sarkozy qui
ont eu affaire là des meilleures
poutines dans des moments de crise
importante notamment lors de l'annexion
de la crimée pour françois hollande ou
lors de la guerre en géorgie pour
nicolas sarkozy françois hollande qui
s'est exprimée ces derniers jours et qui
a indiqué qu emmanuel macron avait eu
raison de dialoguer jusqu'au bout avec
vladimir poutine d'ailleurs il ya eu un
échange téléphonique que le kremlin a
qualifié d' intéressant et constructif
emmanuel macron et bien françois
hollande lui a va peut-être lui
conseiller de ne pas tenter de séduire
vladimir poutine puisque selon l'ancien
président il n'ya que le rapport de
force qui fonctionne avec le maître du
kremlin il faut se rappeler qu emmanuel
macron avait reçu en grande pompe à deux
reprises la dîmière poutine en 2017 et
2019 emmanuel macron qui veut continuer
à marcher sur le chemin du dialogue même
si comme vous l'avez souligné la france
va dépêcher des soldats du côté de la
roumanie membre de l'otan et puis
emmanuel macron qui s'adressera avec un
message solennel aux sénateurs et aux
députés ont en début d'après midi merci
beaucoup car il